la actualización de la lista roja
mundial sobre las especies en peligro no
es alentador a 38.000 viven bajo amenaza
en distintos grados lo que equivale al
28 por ciento de todas las especies
identificadas una tendencia al menos 100
veces superior a las tasas conocidas de
extinción
la principal amenaza para la mayoría de
las especies de la lista roja es la
pérdida de su hábitat natural a causa de
las actividades humanas a saber la
agricultura la pesca en red y la
explotación minera en el mar y la tierra
y justo después está el uso de las
especies para el consumo humano
ciertas familias de animales padecen una
fuerte presión como es el caso de los
anfibios amenazados hasta en un 41%
entre las especies emblema los dragones
de komodo están en grave riesgo el alza
de las temperaturas con una subida del
nivel del mar podría reducir su entorno
hasta menos de un 30% en los próximos 45
años las especies marinas también están
en la mira con el 37 por ciento de los
tiburones y rayas al borde de la
extinción la causa la degradación del
hábitat marina por la contaminación el
calentamiento climático pero sobre todo
la sobrepesca
si trabajamos correctamente si
explicamos la causa podremos encontrar
un modelo de pesca que no alcance las
zonas marinas protegidas
[Música]
por primera vez la organización para la
biodiversidad también ha publicado una
lista verde que detalla algunos éxitos
en conservación el atún rojo del
atlántico ha pasado de estar en riesgo a
preocupación menor gracias a la puesta
en marcha de cuotas regionales una
inspiración para las autoridades de cara
a la protección de otras especies en
peligro